okay uh but let's talk about the the
quentin tarantino choice you put yes
kill bill i i think volume one okay i
like volume really
i i actually won number one i know
volume two is great
volume two is rated higher and it's a
crime we didn't get another one it's a
legit crime we didn't get a volume three
uh i just think i think in the entire
like uh filmography of queen tarantino
kill bill is just one that i just forget
see the thing for me is like pulp
fiction isn't even like my top five
quentin tarantino really yeah
i think that like glorious bastards
django is better
um
is better than pulp fiction and what
else has he done that's better what
about like jackie brown look look look
maybe jango would have been like one of
his best films if not for jamie foxx i
feel like jamie foxx
was so [ __ ] dry do you know who was
originally casting
will smith will smith they got wilson's
for that movie
holy [ __ ] he wouldn't have
he wouldn't have said half the [ __ ] well
smith would have carried that movie yeah
because they got jamie foxx yeah
christoph waltz had to do the [ __ ]
yeah yeah exactly everyone is
christopher waltz and leonardo dicaprio
i think jimmy fox is great in that movie
what do you remember after the big scene
in the middle uh i think i i actually
can't remember much
that's that's the point because after
that it's jamie foxx who has to carry
the film and he just
doesn't well i think one of the actually
actually like you know everyone focused
on christoph waltz he did amazing and so
did uh
um leonardo dicaprio yeah yeah but like
samuel jackson
is like probably one of the my favorite
things in that film he's
he's so [ __ ] good he's good evil yeah
he's good don't get me wrong
but it's not the best samuel jackson
role
every single [ __ ] role he does is
amazing like samuel jackson kills it and
everything yeah yeah i get that but like
i think his role in like jackie brown
was 100 times better
i just i just think i had more fun
watching one like jackie brown and like
even kill bill
over django i i just i don't think
pulp fiction was that good how dare you
wow yeah i think it was fine there was
just like there was too many scenes
where i was actually bored
during pulp fiction like i the scene
when they're at the restaurant just
talking
was i was bored out of my mind what you
mean the one at the end no no in the
start and start
not right there's not the diner the
restaurant where they're like uh were
they doing like milkshakes
with john travolta oh jack rabbits yeah
i can't [ __ ]
that seems [ __ ] great i just think
john travolta is like not a good actor
i i think he's not good i mean i don't
know if one of these
takes there no john is a badass no no
okay john travolta
is very much samuel jackson carries like
you it's so obvious because when samuel
jackson isn't withdrawn to walter
jonathan sucks okay in my opinion john
scenes were there without those two
together
there were there weren't many like one
or two but like and he was terrible
i think john travolta is terrible but
john travolta is one of those actors
where like
i feel have you seen his recent movies
no but that's
okay the reason why recent john travolta
movies he's clearly like
has just been type casted as the bad guy
because of pulp
fiction right because before pulp
fiction
john travolta just did all the grease
lightning movies right so he literally
went from
he was in greece he literally went from
this like sing-songy like
face-off so suddenly playing as this
like
badass gangster right and because of the
success of pulp fiction
all the movie industry was like we need
a bad guy who's also like kind of quirky
and charming on the surface but is
actually [ __ ] up on the inside
john travolta i mean like pulp fiction
isn't my favorite tarantino movie
i mean i put it on his reservoir like i
still
would put like i i really love glorious
bastards yeah um
would you saying glorious masters is
better than pulp fiction do you do you
i'd say it's about the same i think
glorious bastards is good
it's better than pulp fiction but for
different reasons yeah i i do agree with
you where
there are some parts of pulp fiction
that did drag but when
like i feel like the highs of pulp
fiction are just they're they're like
the best tarantino can do yeah uh kill
bill
is i feel like one of his most killed
different movies
yeah kill build is clearly the movie
where tarantino was like
i like anime by the way yeah i love it
i really like anime i really like japan
it's so cool i just love it everything
about the movie is just so fun
i mean like yeah yeah is [ __ ] awesome
i love the scene with uh uh what's the
name kuriyama who
did go go hibari with like the chain
thing that's so good i love that i just
love
[ __ ] uber thurman's janky japanese
when like go go
go go comes out like swinging the the
that sucks
yeah i mean i feel like on an aesthetic
level there's
a few that are as iconic as kill bills
and also uh the restaurant is still like
open in tokyo
yeah yeah yeah like going there and like
seeing it and be like [ __ ] yeah it's
so cool
when you go to that restaurant you're
also like [ __ ] how did they make this
happen it's
definitely like a culturally significant
movie i mean i mean like
for the record all of quinton tarantino
movies are [ __ ] amazing
uh i just feel like kill bill is like
the most different i feel like
especially in terms of tarantino movies
volume two was felt may way more like a
tarantino movie
i dead ass don't even remember what
happens in volume two she [ __ ] kills
bill
joey joey how do you spoil
joey i can't believe it's spoiled kill
bill it's literally
literally there in the title i've
re-watched the first one so many times
i've barely watched the second one i
don't know why i don't know it's just
like i've definitely seen
kill bill volume 2 a couple of times i
just don't remember what happened
other than the titular i mean i i would
say that the only
film i mean the only seeing out kill
bill that really sticks out to my mind
is the one at the end of kill bill
volume one which is her against
that's oh lucy lou right no not lucy liu
the one with her against like the
[ __ ] what what the name of the uh
gang that she fights that's not the end
the crazy 88 yeah that's like in the
middle
no that's like right before the end
right before the end is when she he
she fights lucy lou yeah that's the
ending yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so the
one
so she fights the crazy 88 before
to me that is like the iconic scene of
the kill bill
but i feel like overall i feel like the
second film was just a little bit better
um i felt like i have to rewatch it
honestly yeah i have to i think
so what why is this your favorite
tarantino movie then i don't know again
i think it's just how unique it is and
how stylized like this i don't
you don't really get a movie like it
anymore i don't know yeah definitely not
it's just such a good movie i feel i
feel like this is the only
successful live-action anime adaptation
you know what i mean
where it's like this feels like it was
based off of i don't know i had actual
[ __ ] anime in it
yeah yeah it's got
everything about that film is just like
him just like just saying hey guys i'm a
weeb and like you said
but but in a good way in a way that
you're like okay it's definitely done
from like a place of like respect yeah
yeah
it's just it's just like you you watch
this and you just feel like this is just
fun
yeah yeah that's great this is just a
director having [ __ ] things
it's definitely the most like turn your
brain off type of attack but it's the
best kind it's the best
because you don't need to turn your
brain off to appreciate this movement
yeah but at the same time it's that
it follows that kind of same style yeah
where you don't have to think much but
everything about this just has impact
yeah absolutely right
impacts i definitely agree kill bills i
just want to re-watch it now honestly
it's been a while